hey everyone welcome to this video on
cyber security interview questions part
4. here you will be acquainted with
several interview questions on cyber
attacks
our experienced instructor bipin will
take you through these questions
so let's get started but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from simply learn
let's start off with the first one the
first question is what is sql injection
sql stands for structured query language
which is a language that is used by most
of your databases
or your relational databases the
variations of your database would be
mysql microsoft sql oracle sql
you'll have ibm databases all of these
databases utilize the structured query
languages
to interact with the applications now
all of these
databases have their own syntax so
you'll have to study
most of these databases based on which
applications and which databases you
want to
provide security for but as the name
suggests
sql injection vulnerability or
structured query language injection
vulnerability
is where a user can maliciously inject
a sql input or a sql statement
in a query and send it to the database
and evoke a response
response out of it so this vulnerability
is not
specifically to the database it uh the
vulnerability lies more in the
application and the coding of that
application
so when the application receives a query
which it needs to be forwarded to the
sql
uh database we need to configure and the
application level
of what queries are allowed and what
queries are not allowed so there are
different various
aspects of how to manage a sql injection
vulnerability
but the basic flaw lies in the
application where
uh invalidated input is accepted and
sent forward
to the database where the database might
confuse it
into an executable statement and thus
create
a response that was not warranted
there are various types of sequel
injections as shown on the screen
in band sequential where you can look at
an error based or a union based
injection
a blind sql injection where it is either
boolean based or a time-based
attack and then an out-of-bound sql
injection
essentially you're looking at databases
and you're looking at application
security
where you want to encourage secure
coding practices so in
unvalidated input is mitigated
the next question is what is spoofing
now in spoofing
you're basically assuming the identity
of another person
so here the attacker pretends to be some
other person or an organization and
sends you an email
that appears to be a legitimate email it
looks almost
genuine it has been constructed to
replicate
what a genuine email would have been and
it is very difficult to spot
a fake one there are different ways to
identify whether an email
is genuine or not but that's for a
different video
moving on to the next question what is a
distributed denial of service attack
or a ddos attack now generally a denial
of service attack is an attack
where legitimate users are prevented
access to the resources that
they legitimately can access right so
for example if it is
a bandwidth-based attack the attacker
consumes the bandwidth of the network in
such a way
that there is no more bandwidth left for
legitimate users
to access the network now a single
device may not be able to generate that
much amount of
traffic to consume the bandwidth of a
huge server
thus the attacker will construct a
botnet
and through that botnet they will launch
a distributed denial of service attack
to the target victim right so a botnet
uh there are two uh terms that you want
to look at over here the first
term is a bot and the second one being
the botnet itself
bot is a software that once installed on
a victim's machine
allows the hacker to send remote
commands to that machine
that will make it to generate some
activity
once we have enough machines on which
such bots
have been implemented the collection of
these machines
would be known as a botnet so an
attacker would then instruct this entire
botnet
to start generating data traffic to be
to be sent to the targeted network or to
the targeted server
which will then bog down the server thus
crashing it and preventing
users from accessing that particular
resource
the next question is how to avoid our
poisoning
or arp now first let's understand what
arp is
arp stands for address resolution
protocol which is a protocol used by
computers to communicate over the
network
once your computer boots up it starts a
discovery process
of identifying its neighbors so if i'm
in a particular subnet
my machine will proactively send out a
arb request an address resolution
protocol
to find out which other machines are
within the same network
and which are live once it sends out a
query a live machine will respond to
that query along
with its mac address
this information is then stored in what
is known as a arp table or an arp table
on the machine's cache so whenever my
machine now wants to send out a packet
to this particular machine
it will go to the arp table it will
identify the ip address
and the associated mac address it will
print that onto the data packet
as a destination and destination mac
and send that packet across to the
switch the switch will then identify the
mac address
and send the packet to the relevant
machine that is
connected to that particular switch now
to confuse the switch
into sending it to a different machine
our poisoning attack is
created this attack is generally
launched to create a man in the middle
attack
now to prevent this arc poisoning from
happening in the first place
there are three different aspects that
we can utilize
first we can use packet filtering which
will
filter out and block packets that are
the same source address data so you have
identified some malicious ip addresses
and you want to block out some ip
addresses so you're using a packet
filter firewall
where you have constructed the firewall
to filter out certain packets
originating from particular range of ip
addresses
this firewall and this technique will
then block those kind of packets coming
in
second keeping away from trust
relationships
organizations will develop protocols
that do not depend on trust
relationships
and thus you want to keep this protocol
away from that
once you have created a trust
relationship uh these machines should
not be
sending out arp requests to other
machines in the first place since
uh that translation has been defined and
these machines know whom to communicate
with
such kind of protocols should then be
disabled
or you can use arp spoofing software so
there are some
there are software's out there that will
look for arp spoofing
and prevent that from happening in the
first place so if somebody has sent out
a spoofed arp packet
that packet will be picked up by this
software and
it will be mitigated of network
visualizers like
glass wire antiviruses like so force
they haven't built capabilities of
identifying our
spoofing attacks and mitigate them in
the first place
in the next question we are going to
discuss what is ransomware
now ransomware is a type of malware that
blocks victims to access personal files
and demands ransom to
regain access there are three categories
before we go into the categories
let's just revisit what ransomware is
let's start with the word malware
malware is a malicious software
that poses as a legitimate software but
has a payload
that will have a security impact on your
machine
so in this instance uh viruses trojans
all of these can be classified under
malware so can ransomware
a trojan is a software that will give
you a back door access to a diff
to a particular device a virus will do
some destructive activity on that device
a ransomware will basically encrypt the
data
of that particular user from on that
particular machine
thus rendering that that data
inaccessible to the users themselves
and in turn will demand the ransom to
provide access
to that particular data so the three
types of ransomwares
the first one is scareware which uses
social engineering to cause
anxiety or the perception of a threat to
manipulate users into buying unwanted
software
so this preys on the gullibility of
humans
where you can see a pop-up appearing on
your screen
which can scare you into believing that
you may have been attacked
or there is a virus on your machine and
then instructs you to download a
particular software
to mitigate that particular virus now
the malware will be in this software
that you will be downloading
and then a ransomware will be installed
and your data will be encrypted
screen lockers where locking uses
computers by preventing them
from logging in and displaying an
official looking message
you will see a screen saver once you
boot up which prevents you from
accessing the login page so it will not
allow you to log into your own machine
but it will give you a warning that your
data has been encrypted and you need to
connect to
a particular email address and same bit
to send bitcoins over there
to get a decryption key to access your
own data
and then the encrypting ransomware
displays a message demanding payment in
return for the private
asymmetric key which is needed to
decrypt the symmetric keys for encrypted
file
so once your files have been encrypted
you might just have a blank screen in
front of you
where you'll receive a warning message
uh where it instructs you to pay up
a ransom in bitcoins or in some
cryptocurrency
to some particular digital e-wallet
which is not traceable
and once you make that payment they will
send you the decryption key and then you
can access your data
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more then talking about the
next question what is the difference
between an active and a passive cyber
attack
now when we talk about cyber attacks
cyber attack is an
activity that is caused by a malicious
user who wants to try to
get access or do some security incidents
on the victim's devices so there are two
ways that can happen
it's either in an active manner or a
passive manner in an active manner the
intruder attempts
to disrupt a network's normalcy modifies
data
and tries to alter the system's
resources so this is more active
where the attacker will proactively try
to
destroy the network so that
communications fail
or they might try to modify the data
where uh
we're using a ransom where they can
encrypt it or they might delete that
data using a virus
or steal that data using a trojan or
they might even
alter the data so that it is no longer
trustworthy whereas in a passive attack
the intruder intercepts data traveling
through a network here the intruder
eavesdrop but does not modify the
message so they're just listening in
they're just observing what is going on
they are not manipulating the data they
are not stealing anything
it's just that they are monitoring the
activity that's going on
the next question what is a social
engineering attack
now social engineering attack is a
people based attack the victim here
is the human by itself the vulnerability
also lies in the human
it may be executed through a computer
but
end of the day the calibrity is of the
human so it is the art of
manipulating people so that they end up
giving up confidential information
now we always read in the papers where
somebody got manipulated their passwords
got hacked and somebody's life savings
got wiped out
right because they shared the otp with
someone or they shared
the password with someone now creating a
scenario where these people
will fall prey to this attack and share
this kind of personal information
to unknown people that is where the
social engineering attack comes in
creating that scenario which will ensure
that these people give out this
confidential information
now there are three categories in this
attack one the first one is a phishing
attack
second is a sphere phishing attack and a
third is a railing attack
now phishing attack is basically a
generic attack
it is targeted to the world at large
whoever falls prey to that
attack will be a victim whereas a spear
phishing attack
is a targeted attack towards a specific
individual or a group of individuals or
towards an organization
so there is a lot more research that
goes into spearfishing
where you analyze the victim you try to
figure out what their vulnerabilities
are
and you tailor make or you customize the
attack
to that particular vulnerability once
you have that attack you launch it
against those people
those people will then fall prey to this
attack
an availing attack is when you're
attacking
uh top level executives so the c-level
executives of an organization
politicians movie stars wealthy and
powerful people
so any of these people when they're
attacked it will be known as a
whaling attack next question what is
man in the middle attack now this is
something that we had touched based when
we talked about arp
where the arp poisoning attack needs to
be executed
to leverage a man in the middle attack
now in the man in the middle attack
the attacker attacking computer takes
the ip address of the client
unaware of this the server continues to
communicate with the attacker now
if you remember in a previous question
we have also talked about spoofing
so in this scenario uh attacker has
spoofed
their ip address to replicate themselves
as a
genuine client and now with that
spoofing in mind they might either
through
our poisoning attack or just because of
the spoofed ip address
become a man in the middle that means
that they are now
each dropping on the conversation
between the actual
client and the server by posing
themselves
as a server in this scenario the
attacker
is now a go-between between the client
and the server and can eavesdrop and can
copy the data
if they want they can modify the data as
well so as you can see on the screen
the attacker becomes man in the middle
which means that they are now
eavesdropping on the conversation that
is happening between the client
and the server the next question who are
blackhead hackers and whitehead hackers
the main thing is the differentiation
between a blackhead hacker and a
whitetail hacker
now our blackhead hackers are skilled
individuals
who illegally hack into a system the
motive behind such an attack is mostly
for monetary gain
these individuals are known also known
as security crackers now if you look at
your criminal hackers
those who have malicious intent those
who do hacking for the intent of
personal gain or for the matter of
disruption
the main thing that black hat hackers
lack
is authorization they are not authorized
to do the activity that they are about
to do
and they are going to get unauthorized
access to devices or to data which is
going to cause losses
to the organization involved whereas on
the other side a white hat hacker
are also known as ethical hackers these
are the individuals who discover
vulnerabilities in a computer network
and they help the organizations mitigate
these vulnerabilities
they help the organizations defend
themselves from blackhead hackers
so the main difference between these two
types of hackers a black hat and a white
hat
is the intent and the authorization so
black hat hackers will have malicious
intent they will try to
personally gain from that attack from by
finding out vulnerabilities
they also will not have authorization to
conduct whatever activity they are doing
whereas on the other side whitehead
hackers will be hired by organizations
they will provide authorization for
certain activity that the whitehead
hacker can do
to find out those vulnerabilities once
those vulnerabilities have been find out
found out by the whitehead hacker
they will report it to the management
and guide them in
implementing security controls to
mitigate those vulnerabilities
the main difference between a black hat
and a white hat is the authorization
and the intent the next question what
are honey pots
now honeypots are a very interesting
device that can be introduced in a
network uh
these basically are decoy servers that
are implemented in a network to
attract the attention of attacker it is
there to lure an attacker
into uh attacking that particular device
thus creating a security blanket blanket
for the rest of the devices
so if an attacker has been able to
bypass a firewall
and is now trying to scan a particular
network when they scan they will
come across various devices that are
there in the network they will then
proceed to do a vulnerability scan
on these devices the honeypot at that
point in time
will provide as an approve as an
attraction to these attackers because it
will
demonstrate some vulnerabilities to the
hacker
which will divert their attention so
these vulnerabilities are simulated on
these devices these actually do not
exist
but the moment the attacker then starts
interacting with the honeypot
the honeypot will identify that as a
malicious traffic and will
warm the one the administrator about a
possible attack that is going on
the administrator will then investigate
through the honeypot of what activity is
going on
and then reconfigure their security
controls to block the attacker or
mitigate the attack itself
right so it is more of a decoy server
uh that will showcase or simulate some
vulnerabilities
to an attacker thus to lure them and
safeguard the rest of the network and
with that we have come to the end of the
cyber security interview questions part
4
on cyber attacks i hope it was
informative and interesting
if you have any questions related to the
topics that were covered in this video
please ask away in the comments section
below our team will help you solve your
queries
tune in to simply learn to watch out for
more cyber security interview questions
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here